Justin how much of screenwriting is
about packaging a lot actually packaging
is kind of the new normal I think
but packaging is also tricky because if
you are going to package your material
and you are going to get a first-time
director and actors with no credits and
producers that haven't produced a lot of
things you're gonna have an uphill
battle
so packages should be utilized when you
can have a component that's gonna help
you out as a writer so attaching a
director who has credits or attaching an
actor who is bankable that's really
going to help you so what I usually do
is I will have a package no matter what
with any project that I move forward
with like my most recent one you know
attaching someone like if we can get a
Sam Rockwell that will be helpful for us
because he's bankable and he's great
actor now that being said I will take
out a package with the actors attached
with the director attached but if I take
it to a studio or a production company
or producer and they say we love the
script we love the project but we don't
necessarily love the package we want to
develop this from within we want to have
our own director we want to get our own
director we want to get our own actors
we want to go through that process then
I will always say that's fine the
project is clean and clear then so I
think it's smart for writers to always
have that package in their back pocket
but to know that it's not something that
they necessarily have to rely on if all
of the pieces come together and you can
get a big name attached that's probably
going to help you get it done but if you
can't get those big names or bankable
actors the package isn't necessarily
going to help you and I would also say
that for independent film makers
especially though we're primarily going
to you know outside investors sometimes
investors who have an investment
films or have invested in very few films
so if you can attach a few names that
maybe aren't household names as actors
but are recognizable and have some good
credits sometimes that can help you it
just depends on the budget range of the
film that you're trying to do so if it's
you know an independent film that's not
a really high budget and you have the
right components in a package and you're
going out to outside investors then
that's a good place to to take it as
well
you